sure everybody is mostly talking about
how warm we all are however we'd like to
talk about how warm things can get do
you guys know the meaning of the term
Netflix and chill this is a great segue
by the way that was a great Netflix and
chill I do that almost every night you
just literally get your popcorn get your
tacos and you lay down and you just
chill maybe like watch stream
binge watch some TV show on Netflix and
take off our clothes in the air canoe
hashtag mama knows what she's talking
about Netflix and chill means we're
gonna watch the TV but when not what are
you gonna do
fingering that's what we do my mother
and I and my children and my wife
bringing up Netflix and we chill so
that's all we do in our house is watch
Netflix and chill
however kids today are changing the
meaning of Netflix and chill and now
it's an invitation to sort of hook up
like you want to come over and Netflix
and chill and I don't mean a Netflix and
chill I would assume you stick something
on Netflix and just chill it wasn't one
of the trickier conundrums you know you
don't need the guy from the imitation
game to solve that one what does that
mean it means you're a freak really
people want to hook up when they watch
orange is the new black you watch
Netflix with the air conditioning on
basically it means when a man loves a
woman and they equally love Netflix they
get together and magic happens
I mean to come over plug she nailed it
how's that make you feel
picturing kids hookup great I love it
these kids and their sex they're also
Horning everyone's mind now the kids are
those I got my horny gland I moved you
got every move is called your yeah your
landed you give me the name of your guy
it's a baby no removal calm I got
Netflix chill with myself last night I
did all I got Netflix show big time with
myself yeah if you could Netflix and
chill with anybody who would you choose
you Jack Nicholson really that'll be the
most terrifying chilling ever are you
serious that's like the dream
has anyone ever got just lost in your
eyes before descending to tell you that
I've been told they look like pools in
the ocean but they're beautiful you've
got to quit I've just never seen it up
close out of the scope no you've gotta
stop you gotta stop this ends one way
you don't write a check and you can't
cash I'm ready and I will go and just
your office is right around the corner
from my office it's already dangerous
I'm just saying if we start something
maybe we could finish it how can I quit
you I'll never be able to crown you
those beautiful